[Applause]
it's pretty clear that you really
enjoyed watching 2021's edition of those
flexes i'm not surprised to be honest so
let's continue to ride the momentum with
another treat for you all today we'll be
having a second list on top anime flexes
however we won't be confining it to 2021
shows but instead we're gonna focus on
another qualifier main characters who
doesn't like main characters putting on
a show of their power so strap
yourselves in and let us take this ride
through some of my favorite moments of
anime main characters showing off
zero release
man what a moment hell sing ultimate has
been full of badass moments and i think
that a few anime characters can come
close to embodying that concept as
alucard an overpowered character in his
own right already
takes it up a complete notch with this
release moment many goosebumps have been
raised when alucard finally enters his
full power after a harrowing chant i
think that what makes this thing so
awesome is that it encapsulates what
alucard has done to get to this point
yeah he's an anti-hero fighting for the
side of relative good but it also sheds
light on how alucard is also the
representation of vileness releasing
devoured souls to fight by his side is
clearly not a good guy move you know and
at this point i'm pretty sure helsink
was more than happy that this guy is
fighting on their side than against them
because i can't imagine how anyone would
feasibly deal with that
i also like shiki ryogi taking on
apartment zombies
compared to how ridiculous alucard's
level zero transformation was this one's
way tamer still it's a moment to
remember from one of my favorite movie
series out there back in those days
though can you imagine a fight sequence
with choreography as silky smooth as
this one cheeky just armed with a knife
takes on all those apartment zombies and
solos them one by one many against one
and it didn't even matter how the
zombies approached they're nothing but
fodder getting killed and thrown out
after one another shiki did all of this
in a kimono too she just can't keep
herself from looking stylish even when
being a one-woman wrecking crew against
all those zombies it's a massacre that
looks more like a dance if you ask me
perfect just perfect for this deadly
beauty
[Music]
from one cinematic production to another
we have kirito from ordinal scale
kirito is being called a lot of things
overpowered is just one of them but if
you step back and take a look he's
nothing more than just a very very
skilled gamer yeah he's had his hax
moment but he's never really done
anything to the realm of say one
shooting a boss on his own or something
oh boy i mean that all changed in
ordinal scale for a moment after one
hell of a climactic boss fight kirito
and the gang have technically cleared
einkrad something they weren't able to
do before and the reward from kayaba's
ghost himself a godsword that puts every
weapon to shame with one swoop boss
monsters back in the concert hall fell
like flies multiples of them exploded
with each swing of the god sword in a
moment which makes me think it's an
intentional joke on the writers part oh
you said kirito's op okay here you go
god mode for kirito for 15 seconds
nothing he ever did in the series comes
anywhere close to this absurdity
i mentioned the last moment with some
comedic undertones so how about moving
on to sight armor
one of my favorite things about one
punch man is how it takes the absurdity
of overpowered protagonists up to 11.
apparently done right as they'd say it's
been established that saitama is able to
be any villain standing in his way with
just one punch but just how would he
fare against a gigantic meteor that
ominously looms over the city we're
really asking that question of course he
easily demolishes that thing in one of
the hair-raising moments of awesome mad
house animation one punch is all he
needs before breaking that thing into
several pieces in hilarious twist he
still doesn't manage to save the city
which gets pelted into oblivion by the
smaller pieces from the giant meteor
leaving a ruined city in his wake
saitama's done his job i mean hey the
city didn't escape damage at all but at
least it wasn't annihilated by the
meteor right the last still happens
afterwards but as far as this moment is
concerned it showed that saitama's
strength isn't only good against
villains and intergalactic invaders
now while that may be absurd do you
think it can compare to afro-samurai's
bridge scene
saitama crushing a meteor may be a good
show of strength but i think that in
terms of choreography afro samurai's
flex of his own takes it to a whole new
level i'll probably let the video do the
talking in terms of showing just how
overpowered afro is meanwhile i'll just
be amazed at the animation and how
creative he gets when unleashing hell
against those helpless flies he really
did just breeze through everyone while
outright demolishing them without even
breaking a sweat i mean this is just
crazy a river of blood does follow afro
wherever he goes to the point that even
something as mundane as crossing a
bridge is a chance to showcase more
violence and want and destruction he
does deserve the title of being the
world's strongest now don't you think
you feel on this list so far if yes i'd
like to ask for your subscriptions we're
making some good headway with the goal
of a million subs within the middle of
the year and your subs could be the ones
we need to get over that hump and hit
that sweet sweet 1 million sub milestone
i really would appreciate your help on
that one that's all let's get back to
the list
let's move on to one of the more
traditional shonen titles now and one
thing that i'll always remember is
ichigo throwing eyes in
[Music]
for multiple arcs eisen has been a thorn
in the side of the shinigami outsmarting
them overpowering them it seems the isen
can never be stopped with the hokyoku on
his side it just isn't fair is it this
guy just spent an entire arc tanking and
no selling everything that the heroes
can throw at him only to keep evolving
into a new form heck even death and
decay from within wasn't enough to put
him down but then
ichigo arrives this isn't just ichigo
this is ichigo in peak form having
trained for so long inside the dhan guy
and transcended shinigami limits how
does he first demonstrate the fruits of
his training by grabbing eyes in and
throwing him all the way to the
wilderness where their cataclysmic
battle can take place ichigo pretty much
spends the next couple of minutes just
stomping and doing eyes and things to
the man who flexed on the heroes for the
longest time there's even the whole
stopping a sword with a finger thing
how's that for payback
guts versus 100 soldiers is another damn
good moment
there's a lot of things people love
berserk for chief among those is the
scene of guts just showing off his power
for him these soldiers charging him is
nothing more than a chance for him to
prove how head he is compared to
everyone else guts does take some
sizeable hits here but none that are
enough to even slow him down as he
continues his war path by the time it's
done what we're left with is nothing
short of a slaughterhouse with our
triumphant protagonist resting against a
tree with the limitations berserk had in
animation i'd excuse this scene for not
looking like any masterpiece but i know
there's got to be a chance to sneak in a
berserk 2016 joke somewhere said
limitations don't make the moment any
less awe-inspiring though one of my
absolute favorites in the series and an
establishing moment for our protagonist
eins makes it to the list as he utterly
obliterates 70 000 enemies
we've had isekai protagonists show off
their overpowered mess of abilities
before but can anyone have a claim to
fame the same way irons does not too
long ago we had a rumor taking out an
entire army but are they 70 000 i mean
in terms of sheer scale this one beats
that and it further proves that irons is
nothing short of a one-man army by his
lonesome with one stroke ions easily
commits mashed genocide and eradicates
the entire army that numbers in the
thousands it's a moment rightfully
called massacre at kansai plains those
people were nothing but bugs and small
fries to be melted away in the face of
eins's super magic i just wish that this
moment was adapted better the cg while
not being a complete deal breaker did
put quite a dampener on things nothing
but the easiest and grandest showcase of
power for our powerful overlord all hail
and summer
[Applause]
and finally we head to one piece
seems like i keep talking about one
piece eh well i think it's a good way to
close the book on the list talking about
one of my faves there's a lot of great
moments that evoked a lot of emotions
for me but for the context of this list
luffy versus fishman's gotta be right up
there the moment has some comedic appeal
for me it may not be played off as a
joke scene but in hindsight it's
hilarious seeing everyone's scare
reactions when luffy just so easily
disposes of them all none of the straw
hats even needed to take to the stage
even when most of them are getting ready
luffy just single-handedly wrecks half
of them with his conquerors haki no
other super attacks unleashed no punches
thrown his conqueror's haki is just that
strong to deal with an entire army by
its lonesome quite the memorable moment
we have here for you to ask me
so here's the age-long question which
among these moments is your favorite if
you've got any more suggestions for
protagonist flexes let me hear your
thoughts in the comments section below
and before leaving i'd like to invite
you to join my patreon financial support
will go a long way in helping me make
better videos and i want nothing more
than to give you even better production
quality and other perks as well so i
recommend you head on to patreon and see
what all the buzz is about you can also
connect with me through instagram for
the latest news on the channel thanks
for watching the video i hope you
enjoyed it and i hope to see you next
time we'll meet again
[Music]